[Music]
it's been an exciting couple of months
in KY points regeneration areas earlier
this month the new community BMX track
was officially opened it was a great
turnout from keen riders both young and
old who lined up to try out the track
the opening had been highly anticipated
and the ribbon was cut by Olympian Trent
Jones who designed and built the track
designing the track I wanted to be able
to cater for a wider audience of cycling
and n BMX and that stems from beginners
who have never ridden a BMX track
football or wait to myself who are been
fully professional many of the people
attending including Trent were members
of the old cowboy BMX club they lost
their club track as a result of damage
caused by the September 2010 earthquake
it's kind of cool to be able to build
this one and reinstate a BMX track here
after growing up in quietly writing a
tracks in the town center the Khoikhoi
marine precinct is now open for business
following dredging over winter and the
installation of the final 112 meter
floating pontoon the council has already
received several applications for
long-term berths space has also been set
aside for casual and short-term use and
for the river Queen the kya point dog
park is also nearly ready with the
walking tracks fences and gates all
complete that has separate areas for
small and large dogs and is expected to
open to the public and a few weeks time
once the grass is fully established
nextdoor a recent community planting day
saw residents and visitors planting
another 600 native seedlings and the
honda forest the regeneration focus now
turns towards the sports fields with
team does recently sought for the
construction of the changing facilities
softball diamonds and surrounding roads
[Music]
you
[Music]